- Good morning, everybody.
I think we are all set to begin.
Thanks for coming this
morning to the third
and final event of this
year's Tanner Lectures
roundtable discussion.
It's been a wonderful event so far
and Achille Mbembe in the middle,
research professor from the
University of the Witwatersrand
in Johannesburg needs no further
introduction at this point.
Joining him this morning are two treasures
from the Yale faculty.
Inderpal Grewal is a professor affiliated
with several programs.
Women's Gender and Sexuality
Studies where she is chair.
You're still chair there?
- Yes.
- American studies, Ethnicity,
Race and Migration studies
and the South Asian Studies Council.
I think I've hit them all
but if there are more.
Her latest book out just a few
months ago in fact from Duke
is Saving the Security State:
Exceptional Citizens in
Twenty-First-Century America.
Michael Denning is the
William R. Kenan Jr. professor
and likewise, multiply
affiliated with American Studies,
English and Ethnicity,
Race and Migration Studies.
He also co-directs the initiative
on labor and culture at Yale.
His latest book from Verso
about a few years ago
is Noise Uprising: The Audiopolitics
of a World Musical Revolution.
A word about how we'll
proceed this morning.
Professors Grewal and Denning
will each speak briefly
opening out some questions and issues
from the lectures you've heard
over the last two afternoons.
Professor Mbembe will respond
and our three panelists
will then shape the
conversation as they wish.
After 50 minutes or so,
we'll open the conversation
to questions from the
floor and after that,
we'll adjourn to the
reception room straight down
the hall behind you for a light
lunch and more conversation.
Thank you all for being here.
(attendees applauding)
- Thank you.
I guess I begin.
- [Achille] Okay.
- So first to thank Gary
for making this happen,
for Achille for being here and for giving
two fantastic lectures that resonated
with some of the key questions of the day
and some of the key theoretical
issues that we grapple with
in studying race,
migration, post-coloniality.
So what you said, Achille, spoke very much
to many of our key
concerns, not only topical
but theoretical research wise as well.
And in the second lecture, I
think one of the key issues
that you brought up was
the question of migration
and the movement of Africans around Europe
and North America and what is
called the crisis of migration
but rather is a kind of scandal
and a crime on migration,
one might say in Europe as well.
So some of those questions
really spoke very loudly to us.
And you began in the first
lecture with talking about
a very different kind
of paradigm of mobility
that many of us have been thinking about
and trying to grapple with
not just in thinking about
the present and the ways
in which boundaries, walls
and the bounds of the
nation-state, forms of power
are not enclosures but
are permeable, right?
That they're moving, they're mobile,
we're grappling with the kind of mobility
not just off capital of goods as you said
but also of persons.
But we're also grappling with the mobility
of things that we thought
were stable, right?
The kind of concepts of
bounded nation-states,
the idea of sovereignty, the
idea of Westphalian state,
all of these that you
brought out so importantly.
And one of the issues
that comes out of that
is you what you also spoke
about in the first lecture
which is a question of sovereignty.
Where does sovereignty lie?
How does sovereignty move?
How does it get, you know, you referred
to Saskia Sassen's talking
about, unbundled sovereignty.
And the question there
that I would ask of you
is looking back to the work
of Thomas Hanson and others
that who argues that
the kind of unbundling
and dispersal of sovereignty is not new,
that it was a condition
of colonialism as well.
So one of the issues that
I would want to ask you
to say more about is the question
of not just about the
unbundling of sovereignty
but the paradigm of nobility.
Is it new?
Should we have thought
about it as a question
of a changing formation of nation-state
or do we think about it in
terms of a paradigm shift
in which we have always not addressed
the mobility of people, right?
That mobility is something
that has always been there
but the kind of emergence
of the Westphalian state
and all of these other bounded
enclosure making processes
and disciplinarity have
not allowed us to see it
in some ways and that
we're grappling with it.
So that's one of the questions
that would be really helpful for us,
not just in thinking about the politics
but the organization of knowledge as well
in the university for instance.
About disciplinarity the area
states and national boundaries
as enclosures of thought
as well of knowledge.
So some of that would be,
that's one question that I would ask.
A second question I think is
something that you brought up
also really importantly that
I've been grappling with it
about security regimes.
That securitization of borders of people
is sort of this condition of the present
where development has been securitized,
everything is becoming securitized now
and you you spoke about that as well.
But one of the complex
things about security
is that I think there's an affective
notion of security as
well where people desire
some kind of settlement,
where people desire a care,
welfare, in particular, kinds of spaces.
And when you spoke of the
kind of utopian thought
of mobility of people being
able to move everywhere,
one of the things we'd come up again,
the question yesterday that
Alicia was also asking,
what do we do with people
who want to settle,
who wants something from a
state, who want documents,
who want social security, who won't care,
who want all of these things?
So that would be another
question to think about.
A third would be the
question of technology.
How do we think of surveillance
and technology as again,
not just something a new kind of project
but rather that technology produces fears
and is always harness toward certain
ideological end as well.
So how is what you talked about
as the cellular and fragmented
way in which surveillance
and technology are produced,
sort of part of a longer history, right?
The kind of fingerprints
are a colonial apparatus.
So we have these for a really long time.
So how do we think of those as well
as being part of a history of colonialism
that you have shed so much light on
and helped us understand in so many ways.
So I guess that some of
those would be key questions
to think about in terms of habitation
abode the question of
settling, the question
of people wanting to be in certain places.
And my last point would
the kind of question
of the verticality of
power that you spoke of.
Weitzman and others have talked about
the way we need to think of
power not just as horizontal
or lateral but as from
the sky down, right?
That satellites and technologies
allow us to think of cities and places
in a whole different
kind of optic as well.
And of course, he uses it in
terms of kind of diagnosing
human rights abuses and power.
But I wonder how you would think
about that verticality of power
in relation to technology,
in relation to the kind
of post-colonial project
of migration and enclosure
that you were also trying
to, you know, grappling with
and questioning in all kinds of ways.
So I would put out those
sort of four questions.
- Okay, first of all, I
would like to thank Inderpal
for having been here,
having attended the lectures
and having so attentively and so carefully
drawn out the four pragmatics
she has just shared with us,
all of which I think extremely
useful for any discussion
on question of mobility in our times.
I think you are absolutely
right to insist on the necessity
for grounding all of this
in deeper history
or deeper histories for that matter.
A condition I agree for eliciting
possibly what what might be new
in all that we are seeing right now.
A longer history of technologies,
longer history of forms of power,
longer history of,
of questions you raise
such as national boundaries, enclosures,
modes of thought and forms
of production of knowledge.
So I'll try to not really respond but just
rebound on what it is
that I've heard from you.
I don't think the novelty is
about technologies as such,
talking about technologies in particular.
The novelty stems from,
I would argue, a face of
the history of capitalism
many have characterized as
a phase of acceleration.
The novelty lies in the fact
of our having domesticated speed
at a level and seen before.
I really believe that
this question of speed,
of velocity is what is,
if there is anything new, that is it.
I was referring his day to
the work of Paul Virilio
in particular since he is one
of those who have helped us,
some extent, to understand
the centrality of speed
in the making and remaking of our world.
Domestication of speed
as it is related to the,
in particular this question of light.
I mentioned yesterday almost in passing,
I think I should have been more on that
because a number of technologies
adduced to war, warfare,
security for that matter but
also the production of wealth
in this age of financial capitalism.
Most of them, indeed,
maximizing, forms of
maximization of speed.
They rely on speed.
The new forms of capitalism rely on speed.
I refer to algorithmic trading.
There a number of new studies
of those forms of exchange
that show indeed extent
to which they in fact
rely as resource of speed.
So speed seems to me to be the novelty.
And the organizing principle
for their forms of life,
we were referring to.
Now, if indeed speed is
becoming the resource
for the remaking of our world,
it goes without saying that the,
that the ultimate forms of sovereignty,
the most efficient ways
of exercising power
have to do with how to capture speed
and how to redistribute
speed in an equal ways.
So those who
must go slow if you want
to put it like that.
And who are those who
might not be able to move?
Who are those who might
be able to move at a speed
with a velocity that is unequally?
It seems to me that's how we
have to frame these questions
in this age.
As far as the organization
of knowledge is concerned,
and a lot of our knowledge
in the humanities,
in the social sciences and
probably in other fields
is predicated on sedentarity.
It is predicated on
people settled somewhere,
moving of course back
but moving from within
a space that is delimitated
as fundamentally in
enclosed locations, places
so forth and so on.
So our knowledge mirrors somewhat
this partition of the world
that is predicated on sedentarity.
And if indeed we live in an era of,
as I was suggesting is the
planetary entanglement,
obviously, this requires different forms
of production of knowledge.
Itinerant knowledge for instance.
It requires new imagination
of institutions, university,
that wouldn't have walls for instance.
University beyond walls,
knowledge beyond walls.
And these experiments are already being...
There are places where such
experimentations are going on
where people experimenting
with forms of knowledge
that would be bounded either
nationally originally,
forms of knowledge that would circulate,
knowledge is in circulation.
It seems to me that is the challenge
this kind of analysis poses.
One last thing verticality of power,
Isa Habreder Iali's work.
And in fact Hazel raised
the same issue informally
the other night at a dinner.
What about the vertical that
which comes from the sky,
how do we take into consideration
not only the sea or the
desert but also the air?
And I think it's a very important question
but what strikes me is that in fact
is the fact that it's
the every articulations
of all these optical points of view,
it's not the privileging
of the sky as such.
No, is it the privileges of
terrestrial or the maritime.
The process of conversion of the maritime
into the terrestrial,
the terrestrial into sky,
it's that circulation between
different optical points
of view which seems to me to be going on.
And which seems to me to be producing
an entirely new paradigm
of power, sovereignty
and domination.
And the transformation of all
of this into codes and data.
Including the transformation
of the human itself
into a code and into a data.
And therefore the,
the distance, let's say
they're leaving behind us
of all moral the human with which
the humanities have been working.
The human appended to to an object.
The human appended to an animal,
the human appended to
different other species beings
and all that captured into codes and data,
that is what seems to
me to be the novelty.
So long and torturous
answer to your question.
- So can I press you in one question?
- Yes, yes.
- Which is that some people,
some thinkers are talking about in the,
you mention of algorithms
that is now sovereign
is what is sovereign is data.
That we're now thinking about
an unbundling of sovereignty.
We have seized that kind
of sovereignty of data
but on the other hand--
- The sovereignty is one who--
- The kind of racial algorithm argument.
- Definitely.
- Also suggests that data
is not that sovereign
all on its own, that that's informed
by the very forces that--
- It is, it is absolutely informed.
It is shaped and reshaped
by various other factors.
Including race, gender,
class and the rest.
It's not neutral nor is it objective.
It's not at all objective.
- I could continue but let me ask
a couple of other questions
which I think are actually
from the other side
of your account of
geopolitics and biopolitics.
You gave us powerful, I wanna thank you
for the powerful account of
the mobile and portable border,
the way border work and border processing
and border enforcement can
move anywhere in some ways
and is now in the
interstices of daily life
and it made me think of how
across the traffic routes
in particular where mobile beings move,
not only airports with
their various security lines
which were so aware but
I was thinking indeed
of roads and highways
with their speed cameras.
They're easy passes, the rules of the road
that have actually made driver's license
is such an important issue
for undocumented workers
and for migrants in that kind of way.
And I also actually wanna thank you
for that powerful assertion
of the right of all mobile
mammals to move around the Earth,
to extend as you said to the
poor members of the Earth
that taken for granted
rights of the US passport.
But I wonder whether the issue of borders
and the question of movement
are really the same question.
Because it's as you yourself put it,
the business of a border to be crossed
and movement might be nothing more
than the crossing of borders.
I was thinking this morning as I crossed
from the town of Guildford
into the city of New Haven.
That moment when we crossed the border
from Connecticut in New York
and see the looming towers of Manhattan
and that sort of excitement.
And whether or not borders
are really about movement
or the issue of free movement
then as you also said at one point
about the ways of classifying people.
And if what you mean by a borderless world
is not a world of free
movement but a world of not,
where people are not classified.
And that might be a
different way to think this.
So let me ask two
questions following that.
One on the biopolitics and
geopolitics of sovereignty
which you raised and one on one might call
the bioeconomics and
geoeconomics of accumulation.
So the first, I'm kind
of intrigued to hear more
about the implications
of Ghana's right to abode
as a kind of refiguring.
What what are the
philosophical implications
of that refiguring of sovereignty
which from my very quick study
seems to involve two different aspects.
One is the right of Ghanaian's
to move freely in Ghana,
the right to leave and enter Ghana,
immunity from expulsion from Ghana,
exactly the right that i
had to drive from Guildford
to New York or to California in that way.
But secondly and more remarkably,
the extension of that
right in the Act of 2000
as I understand it to a
person of African descent
in the diaspora, that's the quote.
And so this a right that includes
the right to remain indefinitely,
the right to work without a work permit,
the right to come without a visa,
the right to have children and dependents
covered by that same abode.
And so I guess my question
is do you raise this
as fundamentally a part of
a politics of reparations.
Is this really a sense of
repairing the forced confinement,
the chained migration of
the Atlantic slave trade,
the divisions of the continent
you talked about in Berlin
or is this a sense that the full freedom
of movement of mammal, human mammals
depends perhaps less on an
abstract call for open borders
than on the repair of
specific migratory circuits,
historical circuits on the
reforging of the lengths
of what our president has
denounced as chain migration.
And the second question, so
that's all one question I guess.
You powerfully begin both
days with the question
to whom does the Earth belong
and who determines its
partition and distribution.
And yet your answers
focused, vitally, no doubt,
on the borders that were
maintained by sovereign states.
But doesn't the question of
the partition of the Earth
also depend as much on
as different capital, as private property
owned by transnational corporations
with no trespassing signs there,
border work that's done by
an army of security guards,
often staffed by those mobile migrants
and they disproportionately
with the temporary issuing
of permits and passes
to get on to those spaces as
well as the gated communities
of private homeowners.
Again, both of those in
some ways outside the state,
again serviced by the labor of migrants
but who are off-limits to those ones.
And I guess, so I would
wonder how does one imagine
and this is really to
return to Alicia's question
which I won't try to repeat but
I'll actually just quote her
from a written piece because I couldn't,
but how do we imagine a
new mobility of humans
that isn't simply the flexibility of labor
for the movement of
capital but a new kind of,
in here's where I'm quoting her,
a new kind of migrant justice
that would allow migrants
to achieve and exercise social power
without obtaining formal citizenship
where migrants would be
binational civic actors,
whether some kind of space
between not being a citizen
or being a citizen and whether that raises
and I guess the final question then
is partly you quite provocatively
suggested that mobility was the motor
of social and economic change
and not actually internal
struggles inside a society.
And I was intrigued at
whether having thought so long
and hard about changes in
20th century South Africa
and across the South African continent.
Is it true?
What were the forms of mobility
that actually caused those
social transformations
and economic transformations?
So as to see how migrants
might in the 21st century
so reshape the world.
- Yes, okay.
So all very interesting
comments and questions.
Let us speak first about the
right of abode since you,
you picked it up as a key element
of yesterday's presentation.
I don't think that in the
Ghanaian understanding,
it is conceived as being
part of the fourth freedom
we spoke about yesterday.
It's not,
at least not immediately thought of in,
in those terms.
In terms of Ghana or
Africa for that matter,
being able to institute
a regime of flexible labor,
market labor circulation
and so forth and so on.
That is taken care of by the treaty
that has just been signed in Kigali
which I referred to yesterday.
The single market treaty which would allow
possibly the movement
of labor from places,
production to the rest.
So the right to abode now
encompasses a number of aspects.
It is,
its aim is to make sure as you indicated
that Ghanaians and Africans in general
or people of African descent
take ownership of this
specific space called Africa.
Ghana being one instanciation
of that larger space.
Which would mean they
have the right to come in,
they have the right to settle,
they have the right to work,
they have the right to be taken care of
insofar as the state
attends to matters of care.
And they have the right to come and go.
But the right of abode is also
understood as a specific right
extended to people of African origin
not for as a result of
historical circumstances
have happened to be located elsewhere.
It is similar in that sense
to the right of return
Israel has instituted for
Jewish people, Jewish diaspora
and you're absolutely
right to suggest that
there is a reparative element in it.
And an implicit recognition
of the responsibility of African powers
in the whole business of
the Atlantic slave trade
in particular.
But these reparative element is also
has to do with self reparation.
And in fact, in the juridical debates
that preceded the
adoption of this specific
article of the constitution,
that reparative dimension
was explicitly spoken about.
So,
it seems to me that
the concept of the right to abode
is somewhat of a response
in the part to the question
you were asking, saying
some people want to settle.
Some people want to to be taken care of.
So it's part of that.
It's part of an attempt at making sure
that people of African
descent or African people
find on this Earth that
presumably belongs to all,
a place where they do not have to justify
who they are, why they are there
and what they are doing there.
Where to be black is no longer liability
because they doesn't
seem to be such a place
in our world right now
away you are not forced
to justify why you are black.
So the right of abode would be
that mechanism that allows you
to not have to be classified
and to not have to justify
why you are who you are.
That's how I would expand
the concept of reparation
when applied to these
specific type of right.
You also right to suggest
that there are various
modalities of partition of the Earth.
We have the Westphalian
model where states apportion
parts of the Earth and
distributed among themselves
but there are other modalities that are,
I'm not suggesting the esteem
but maybe not strongly enough
operated by the works of capital.
In a place like such as Johannesburg,
in the aftermath of a
parting urban planning
by governmental agencies
hardly operates any law.
The city is rebuilt basically by
private agencies.
They decide where they
want to create new suburbs,
they build roads, they give names
to the boulevards and the avenues.
And in buildings as new suburbs.
They reproduce the
mechanisms of segregation
or they ratify
the modes of redistribution of urban space
which used to operate under
the parts of the world.
So it's no longer just
the property of the state,
capital is very much involved in
making, remaking and making borders.
What forms of mobility might cause
what types of transformations?
This is a interesting
sociological question.
In the South African case,
in fact, the collapse of a party,
it was the result of people
mobilizing of course
via political activities
but it was also the result
of the collapse of the past system.
The past system was a
system whereby South Africa
was carved into internal borders
because blacks were not citizens
of the South African state
because they were citizens
of the Bantustans.
They needed permits to come and work
in those places where
they could find jobs.
They were not city residents as such
at a certain point during the day,
I think five o'clock or 5:30,
they were supposed to leave the city
and go and reside in specific places
that were allocated especially for them.
Their presence in the city necessitated
the possession of a pass.
So what happens by the mid-80s
is massive campaign of disobedience
where people decide they are
no longer going to carry passes
and you have an influx,
the influx control laws collapse entirely.
Influx control laws were,
the laws regulating internal migrations
within South Africa itself,
laws which way racially
of course configured.
It collapses, people go into cities
in Johannesburg for instance,
the most cosmopolitan
neighborhood Hillbrow
which was peopled inhabited
early on especially by
people from the Jewish diaspora.
It's overwhelmed by the arrival
of those who are not supposed to be there.
That's how a party becomes
partly and government
in addition goes to the manipulation of,
unleashing of insurrectionary violence.
So we see in this instance how it is that
the capacity for people to move
changes the urban configuration,
it changes completely the ways
in which the apparatus of capture
which is the state operates
and that leads to change.
Let's say social transformations.
But I'm sure we could extend
this example to others as well
in the continent.
So just to finish on that,
I think that there is a...
Migrants have...
Bearers of specific
transformation capacities,
we haven't examined seriously.
Migrants is probably
one of those resources,
those who would like to
change the world today
should invest in eliciting and unleashing.
How?
That's the topic for
the next Tanner Lecture.
- I guess we should open it up to...
Okay, so if I could press you a little bit
on the last question.
I think Michael read the quote from Alicia
which sort of suggests a different kind,
a kind of moving the migrant
away from capture by labor
and capital to something else.
And I'm wondering about the kind of ways
in which European modernity took mobility
as liberatory because it
came from modernist notions
of exile, itinerants,
adventure, all of those things.
So one of the shadows if one might say
of mobility is that
sort of colonial history
of mobility as well, right?
And so the struggle it seems to me
in what Alicia is saying, Michael's
is how to take that shadow
away from migration,
one hand of capital, one
hand of sort of a link
to European kind of project of modernity
to somewhere else and what
that might be is indeed utopian
but how to imagine that utopia
is I think the kind of struggle
that we're dealing with.
Right and what constitutes mobility
as the engine of that
is the other question.
- I think what one would have to take
some very specific cases to answer this.
As I was suggesting yesterday,
in pre-colonial Africa,
mobility was the norm.
It was really the norm.
In some societies what was
not normal was the sedentary.
The fact of settling in a place
and being in the same place
from generation to generation.
You even have historical,
I'm talking about fiction,
historical examples of kingdoms
that were moving kingdoms.
Kingdoms that were not
limited to one territory.
They were constantly in motion.
The same thing with trade caravans.
When the concept of a caravan
applied not only to trade but
also to political formations,
things were on motion
was enormous if you will.
That was the law.
And once again, these
are historical examples.
In West Africa, in Central Africa,
present-day Congo, Angola, all of that,
kingdoms moving from the Atlantic Coast
towards the Indian Ocean
and changing in the context,
bringing on board new people,
capturing new religions,
instituting new social
relations and aesthetic forms.
So that was there.
Now when we talk about
mobility and colonialism,
the colonial logic in that context,
these how it operates.
First of all, it operates
on the basis of settlement.
Settlement along the coast to begin with.
Entrepose, that the combination
of warfare and trade
and missionizing Christianity.
These are the three.
So it operates on the basis
of partition of territory
that is first of all imagined
because it has no borders as such.
It's progressively that
borders are instituted
in negotiations with local inhabitants
but mostly in negotiation
with other European powers
all of which culminates
with the Berlin Conference
which I referred to, first that.
So it's a patchy thing,
absolutely open-ended
and messy, has no rationale.
You have borders, I mean, you take a rule
and basically you trace a line.
It doesn't matter what is there.
It's a big line.
If you have a map of Africa,
look at for instance the border
between Algeria and Mali.
It's just like this.
It cuts through a pre-existing territory
that was totally fluid because
there was the Sahara Desert.
Totally nomadic people seek little of,
and that boom, you put a rule.
Same thing with the border
between Angola and Botswana.
A straightforward line.
No consideration of anything.
People, mountains, rivers.
Some borders consider
rivers and physical markers
but others don't.
So that is what happens with colonialism.
And then when the colonial
state is properly instituted
after conquest and occupation
and when it's operating,
it needs them to regulate
people's movements
and the movement of goods.
The movement of goods is unidirectional.
You have the hinterland
you have the coast.
Anything produced in the hinterland
has to go through the
course and shipped outside.
Extractive economy we have today
which is at the basis therefore
of the regulation of movements.
So you have posts where let's see here,
they specialized in the
production of cotton,
over there, production of palm oil
and you need labor to be
working in these units.
And the biggest problem of colonialism
in the continent was the problem of labor.
Because they didn't seem
to ever be enough laborers.
I mean South Africa, that
is absolutely the case.
They have to go outside of South Africa,
Mozambique, in Malawi, in places
as far as Zambia, Zimbabwe,
Southern Congo to bring labor
to work in the mines in the Witwatersrand.
And in so doing, you create
original constellation
with regulated movements because
these are seasonal workers,
they come and go.
Borders don't really matter that much
in the case of Southern Africa.
They matter and they don't.
They matter because of
the politics of states
but they don't because the economic demand
requires that they be open.
So the business of the current state
is to simultaneously institute borders
but render them flexible
enough to make it possible
for the process of
accumulation to keep going on.
So what is it that,
I want to say in relation
to your question,
I think that we have to
do a proper case study,
kind of exercise in order to
elicit the many different ways
in which colonialism makes,
remakes and makes the borders.
So inherit all of that.
And in fact, I believe that
people within the continent
were able to move more
freely under colonialism
than then after colonialism.
What we see after colonialism
is a crystallization
of state borders.
The emergence of the
border becomes a rent.
It becomes a rent for those social classes
that control the state.
They use it to extract rents
which was not the case under colonialism,
which aggravates,
let's say diminishes
Africans possibilities
of moving freely within
their own continent.
So it's a long response but it just shows
the extent to which I think
when we say colonialism,
there are many different--
- Could I add to that question?
And then we'll throw it out.
It's just your earlier discussion
of speed and acceleration
because it might seem that actually,
acceleration and speed
makes location and space
much more important.
So that the response to the speed at light
of algorithmic trading
is that you actually have to be located
even closer to Wall Street
because of the microseconds that,
the time that it takes
to be engaged in that.
And in many ways that the acceleration
that you were talking about in speed
means that one has to be
more tightly connected
to the infrastructure of speed,
whether that is airports or data lines
or interstates or whatever
that makes it much more
difficult for people
who are what you called go slow
but are actually perhaps
walking at a normal human pace.
- I would add to that.
Not just speed but perhaps scale.
So the potentiality of algorithmic trading
is its ability to capture
vast amounts of money
by scaling out.
By just pennies and fractions
but they're so large
in volume and scale that they become,
so the scalar advancement
it seems to me are critical
in this as well.
- And the connection was simply
under your own explanation
of how the infrastructure
of the ports which at one
sense was an acceleration
and a speeding up of moving
commodities around the world
actually ended up
prohibiting earlier forms of mobility.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- I think we're ready.
- [Mary Evelyn] Thank you very much.
My name is Mary Evelyn Tucker
at the environment school.
I'm sorry, I couldn't
come to the other lectures
'cause of teaching.
So this question would relate to migration
due to climate change
or environmental issues
both in North Africa and
now what we're seeing
in South Africa because of
water depletion and so on.
So I wonder if, you might
have touched onto this already
but I'd love to have your comments on this
because there's 19 million refugees
for climate change alone
now around the world.
But clearly, the African
continent has been particularly
severely hit by drought and other issues.
- It's a combination of
many, many different factors.
Some of them are ecological
and environmental
but some of these ecological
or environmental factors
themselves the product of
human-induced catastrophes.
For instance, the wars
in the Great Lakes region
which comprises the Congo,
Rwanda, Burundi, Uganda,
according to the UN have
caused millions of victims
over a very short period
of time when you add
the genocide in Rwanda
and all that has been going on,
the wars of predation
in the Eastern Congo,
a few million people.
But they have also caused serious
environmental consequences
which were not there before the war.
So the war produces ecological
catastrophes which in turn
result in further, further wars.
Most of them was of extraction cobalt.
I mean when every time
you open your computer,
a lot of your computer
parts of your computer,
they are coming from there.
They are coming from the Kumu.
Your computer to a large
extent is made up of wealth,
mineral wealth extracted from the Congo
as a result of the
militarization of the economy.
Militarization,
paramilitarization of the economy.
The two combined.
So the extractive part
and the abstract part
all together linked in a
continuum we do not study
because we study economics of extraction
as if they were just located there
and the financialization
as part of Wall Street
but there is a link between
Wall Street and Eastern Congo.
So people migrate for
all kinds of reasons.
I mean in Johannesburg,
I have been living in
Johannesburg for the last 17 years
and we see the city changing.
Entire neighborhoods, people
only speak in Lingala,
some other languages from
the rest of the continent.
These are people who,
some of them are running away
from terrible political systems.
Others are coming because
they want to make a living.
They will live better,
they will earn little more.
They will send money to the
places where they come from.
So the reasons are many.
They are busy, I mean.
It's a serious matter, of course.
The question of water and water politics
is a geopolitical question.
It's in South Africa.
It is the result of long years of drought,
it's also the result of,
I would say bad planning.
We know very well that big, big issue
for parts of South Africa is water.
They have been attempts at directing,
capturing parts of the water in the Congo
and linking it up with Southern Africa.
It is possible, the
studies have been done.
There's not enough
political will to do so.
So it's all of that.
But the ecological question clearly
is in some parts of the world
at the heart of process of migration.
It's not the only one.
- [Attendee] So thank
you and thank you all
for your kind references
to my thing on this work.
I wanna say again thank you.
For me the these lectures
have been extraordinary
invitations to expand our imaginary,
the political imaginary,
the ethical imaginary.
And so I wanted to ask you to perhaps in,
I found your invocation of the
Dogon and the network systems
and the debt systems very illuminating
for showing us other
forms of social relations
tied to land and kinship and
membership to this place.
And I wondered how that might
be placed in conversation
with the traditions of African socialism.
So as to think about another
piece of the hostility
and racism imbued by
colonialism, not only in Africa
but the Americas, in Australia
against the Aboriginal populations
that mobile people were
represented as more primitive
not only because they would not conform
to the sedentary order the
imperative of being sedentary
but because they seemed to be people
who could not be productive users of land
because they did not accumulate.
And the imperative in
the post-colonial era
of as you've written about beautifully
is a new administrative
control of the economies
of the former colonized nations
by insisting and demanding certain modes
of production accumulation.
So I just I wanted to ask you
if there's a way to connect
the vision that you gave
us around the pre-colonial
social worlds and forms of
habitation to another vision
of a African socialism which
is also rich tradition.
Thank you.
- Okay.
There have been historical
experience of socialism
in the continent since
the end of colonialism.
Different kinds of
experiments in Guinea Conakry,
in Angola, in Mozambique.
Even in Senegal.
Senghor for instance was a major
theorist of African socialism.
And of course in Tanzania.
Tanzania was the most advanced experiment
in that sense with Nyerere
and his concept of Ujamaa.
Most of those experiments
have failed, quote, unquote.
They have failed to extend that.
Today, you hardly find anybody,
even doing research on
so-called African socialism.
Most of these from say, theoretical
ideological point of view,
most of these experiments
were aiming at domesticating,
let's say Marx, basically.
There were part of a project
of domestication of Marx
in the conditions of Africa.
And the overall premise
was that these African
societies were governed
by the law of community.
Distinction between what is
communal and what is individual.
And that property relations
were hardly privatized.
Property relations were communal,
land belonged to a community
rather than to individuals.
There was an element of this that was true
and another element that
was highly mythical.
But the politics,
it's about truth, it's also about myth.
Nothing wrong with that.
Now, you are asking me to make a link
between, or as seriously
about African pre-colonial geometrics
and the idea of African socialism.
I don't think there was
a direct connection.
Talking about these
historical experiments.
There was hardly any connection.
There was
an exercise of reinvention of traditions
or some elements of so-called traditions
for purposes of political efficacy.
Otherwise,
what I was trying to say
was that if we look at the different,
call them archives of the world.
Something we could call
the African archive
to be defined on.
If we look at the different
archives of the world,
this allows us to imagine.
Let's say different paradigms
of almost everything
of how gender relations can be organized,
how it is the property
relations are organized,
what types of relations
people have with the divine,
religious field.
There's a multiplicity of paradigms
if we think in terms of the planetary
in terms of the humanity as a whole
which are not reducible to those paradigms
that end up dominating our world,
mostly Western paradigm.
Paradigms coming from one
form of human experience.
So the call was to,
in this age when we are so interconnected,
we cannot produce knowledge
that is simply provincial.
What our world requires
now are forms of knowledge
that are as much as possible
a manifestation of the multiplicities
of the archives we inherit.
So if the debate is about
how to govern mobility
in this century, which by the way,
by the end of this century,
the biggest number of people in our world
will be coming from the
continent of Africa.
By 2050,
Africa will have recovered
the demographic gap
it suffered during the
Atlantic slave trade.
And by the end of the century,
most living beings, human beings on Earth
will be found in the continent.
Nigeria will be bigger,
demographically speaking
than the United States of America.
The youngest people on Earth
will be coming from there.
We'll have a kind of map
of the world population
in which the oldest people and
the smaller number of people
will be located in places such as here,
Europe, Japan, of course,
partly Latin America
and the biggest number of youngest people
will be coming from Asia
and particularly Africa.
So the question of who owns the Earth?
How do we divide it?
How do we apportion it
will be resolved partly
through the demographic calculus.
So demography will become geopolitics.
It's all there is.
And naturally, what we
will see is a process
which is already going on.
We call it migration crisis, whatever.
That's the wrong term.
What is going on is a process of,
I don't know the term in English,
in French it is (speaking
in foreign language).
(speaking in foreign language)
Is the process of, it's
like under colonialism.
Colonialism was a form of
(speaking in foreign language)
of the world.
People go into Australia, South
Africa, Asia and all that.
It won't happen like that
by the end of this century.
because we are beyond colonialism
unless we go and colonize another planet.
But it will happen
through population move,
people moving.
The key is it will be
unlocked by people moving
in spite of borders.
That's how the Earth will
be re-peopled if you want.
I don't know what the term
(speaking in foreign language)
means in English.
You will find it but that's
what I'm talking about.
So, now if you want to
understand, therefore,
that process it seems
to me we have to open
as many archives as possible.
So the question of the
government of human mobility
in this century cannot
be resolved exclusively
by looking into the anti-humanist
archive of the West.
Because when it comes to
borders, people's movements,
the Western archive is anti-human.
It is pro-capital, pro-commodity.
The question of the fourth freedom,
it privileges things over people.
In the continent, if
we look at the archive
of the continent,
people and things are interwoven.
You cannot allow things to move freely
without allowing people to go with them.
Because if you separate
people from things,
you destroy both people and things.
You make the Earth inhabitable.
So the question of the 21st century
is that all question
of the right to abode,
the right to inhabit, the
entirety of the planet
and return when as we
see almost everywhere.
Many abodes are being
rendered and inhabitable
for those who are there.
That's why they want to leave.
They want to leave because
the abode has been rendered
an inhabitable.
So the question is how do we
recover some sense of habitability
whereas I was arguing earlier on,
I don't have to justify who I am
and why I look the way I look.
It entails the end of classification.
The end of classification
as the opening of the world
to all who inhabit it, people and things.
So that's what, I mean,
the whole exercise,
that is what it was.
- [Moderator] I want to say
that we do have more opportunity
for conversation in the reception to come
and it seems to me that that extraordinary
summarizing statement,
an extraordinary summarizing statement.
Not a utopian one but
nonetheless, a futuristic one
and one that shows us
the amazing challenges
to humanity as a whole
that you are posing to us.
That has to be a place
where we stop this part of
the conversation at least
and move on.
So thank you so much to our
main speaker, Achille Mbembe
and to our panelists, Inderpal and Mike.
- Thank you.
Thanks, Mike.
(attendees applauding)